the demands of being House Speaker are
huge in terms of fundraising travel and
overall stress Speaker Paul Ryan says
he's had enough much work remains but I
like to think I have done my part my
little part in history to set us on a
better course a source familiar says
Ryan made the final decision with his
wife Jana over Easter recess and that as
recently as February Ryan considered
running for another term the speaker
told his staff early this morning and
received a standing ovation from his
team Ryan told his Republican colleagues
and reporters family was a key
consideration what I realize is if I am
here for one more term my kids will only
have ever known me as a weekend dad I
just can't let that happen
Ryan also spoke by phone first thing
this morning with his House GOP
leadership team vice president Penson
President Trump the president saluted
Ryan's service on Twitter calling Ryan a
truly good man who will leave an
unquestionable legacy of achievement
among the challenges for Ryan a vocal
bloc of house conservatives who
challenged his leadership a negotiating
partner in the president who at times
could be unpredictable the president
threatened to veto a 1.3 trillion dollar
spending package that he once embraced
another frustration was campaigning for
years on repealing and replacing
Obamacare and the Senate coming up short
the Senate Majority Leader noted Ryan
didn't aspire to be Speaker like a true
leader Paul stepped up to the plate he
answers his colleagues call with exactly
the earnest suppli
that has defined his entire career in
Congress top Democrats sang his praises
to speaker Ryan's a good man he's always
true to his word even though we
disagreed on most air issues in the
areas where we could work together I
found him to be smart thoughtful and
straightforward I found him to have a
great deal of integrity a major
highlight for the policy wonk was the
first tax reform in more than 30 years
and his colleagues say there is still
time I think Paul's gonna be
anything button lame-duck he I think
we're going to be able to get easier in
terms of what's next for the 48 year old
Ryan sources close to him say he's not
going to be having conversations with
anyone about that until January